i'm coming
how was your morning
want one no i don't
want one
well i have some interesting news for
you where were you tess
west end district
hey we had a drop to make
we
we had a drop to make
well you wanted to be left alone
remember
so i'll take one guess the uh
whole deal went south and the client
made off with our pills is that about
right
deal went off without a hitch
enough ration cards to last us a couple
of months easy
you want to explain this
i was on my way back here and i got
jumped by these two [ __ ] all right
and yeah they got a few good hits in
look i managed
give me that
are these [ __ ] still with us
well that's funny
at least find out who they were yeah
look they were a couple of nobodies they
don't matter what matters
is that robert [ __ ] santa
are robert he knows that we're after him
he figures he's going to get us first
son of a [ __ ] he's smart no
he's not smart enough
i know where he's hiding
like hill you do
old warehouse in area five can't say for
how long though
well i'm ready now yeah oh i can do now
is mandatory look at that
ration line hasn't opened yet
it must be running low again
not a lot of ammo
make your shots count
all right texas
so why now
we've been quiet
been planning on leaving the city but
they need a scapegoat
they've been trying to rile us up
looks like they did
we're trying to defend ourselves
sometimes you ever smuggle a kid before
no that's a first
what's the deal with you and marlene
anyways
i don't know
she's my friend i guess
your friend
you're friends with the leader of the
fireflies what are you like 12
she knew my mom
hey
then
what the hell was that
okay
i'm okay then get out quick
[Music]
i'll show you
[ __ ] what's wrong with these
guys catch your breath
we're leaving
okay
watch out
stay down
come here
right now
i'm gonna jump down there and i'm gonna
clear us a path what about me you stay
here this is so stupid we'd have more of
a [ __ ] chance if you let me help i am
you seem to know your way around a gun
you reckon you can handle that
i sort of shot a rifle before
but it was at rats
rats
with bbs
well it's the same basic concept
lift it up
all right now
you're going to lean right into that
stock because it is going to kick a hell
a lot more than any baby rifle
oh yeah
go and pull the bolt back
grab it right there
just hug it there you go
as soon as you fire
you're gonna want to get another round
in there quick
listen to me
if i get into trouble down there
you make every
shot count
yeah
i got this
all right
and just so we're clear about back there
it was either him or me
you're welcome